[Musique]
alors autour de la planète que bienvenus
intertan canada qui est produite en
direct de montréal aujourd'hui vendredi
c'est pas un vendredi 13 non quelle
chance pendant sept ans simplement le
vendredi 8
on a failli passer proche on a passé
proche on n'a pas failli on a passé
proche alors autour de la table ici
aujourd'hui on a deux coéquipiers on est
trois ans tout mais absolument deux
coéquipiers ici je vous explique pas
tant avec les marchés plus clair
matthieu lahaye the bonjourbonjour
stephen barry chopin bonjour oui bonjour
stéphane une chose que matthew est là
parce que si tu fais descendre la
moyenne d'âge des notables de chute
et puis de chances que raymond est pas
là parce qu'il aurait fait augmenter un
peu légèrement plus chaud que la moyenne
mais là on ne donne pas de chiffres non
c'est parce que c'est contre la loi
gallois qui concerne les raffinements
privé c'est à nous faut observer ça
c'est un peu comme si on était des
banques et à vous donner les
informations on n'a pas le droit de
livrer sa à l'antenne
c'est le secret absolu ce qui est secret
évidemment vous le savez c'est le sujet
des missions il serait pour vous est ce
que c'est vraiment un secret pour vous
matthew un oui oui oui
quelques indices mais j'ai fait exprès
de pas creusé à quai pour rester dans
l'inconnu dans l'esprit du jeu alors
elle cette émission bien sûr vous devez
devenir le sujet des missions ont mis je
vous êtes toujours un peu comme un homme
jusqu'au monsieur je vous offre un dans
votre banquier oui je ne restais pas
inventé le tromper vous vous trompez de
personnages ici générosité voici la
vidéo numéro 5 images tout le monde à la
maison au bureau dans l'avion dans les
centres 737 en particulier vous pouvez
jouer avec nous avions le plus populaire
dans le monde
pas de transport passager 737 ça dépend
évidemment dans quelle version vous
voyagez voici premières images
sauf si on est habitué de la voir dans
les médias c'est pas nouveau
qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est quoi ça
on parle de médicaments et cet ébéniste
en deux il était venu au canada pour
montrer que les médicaments coûtent
moins cher au canada qu'aux états unis
mais c'est pas exactement le sujet des
missions qu'elles ont le sujet et on va
parler des médicaments aux états unis
apparaît
mode des médicaments aux états unis
ouais mais dans le contexte canadien
prix du riz les états unis commence à
importer nos ministres canadien et
j'aurais dû mettre une pointe
interrogations à prier pénurie ouais
après pénurie parce que on se pose la
question
et puis ça fait quelques mois qu'on se
pose la question il ya eu d'autres
annonces au sénat qui ont été faits aux
états unis concernant le désir des
américains d' importer nos médicaments
non seulement les démocrates en parle
mais l'administration américaine le dow
jones est passé à l'action a fait
certaines demandes pour moi c'est pas
clair ce qui se passe
le je n'ai aucune idée s'il va y avoir
pénurie additionnel je dirai pas ce
qu'est déjà pénurie de certains
médicaments
moi comme j'ai pas besoin de médicaments
pour le moment je m'inquiète pas trop
mais on a tous des parents et des amis
qui consomment des médicaments certains
qui sont parfois rares non seulement
quel serait l'impact d'une population
300 millions de personnes qui viennent
chercher les médicaments de 37 millions
canadiens voyez l'image est un problème
de deux faciles ou des cas quelque chose
alors là je pense que j'ai en tête qui
est monsieur votre gps et le mois qui
est monsieur belgique
je pense qu'ils les représentants des
pâtes l'industrie pharmaceutique mais
déjà des pharmacies 1 c'est une bonne
idée
je pense que oui alors il dit oui à
chemy la terre on ne la voit pas encore
pour nous les éditeurs mais je pense et
un pétale vous êtes comme dans une
machine à avancer dans le temps vous
avait précédé les choses à peu près de
trois minutes le temps du premier jeu de
la grosse boule à oui c'est moi qui
donnèrent je vous aide là parce que
tellement avancé dans le temps vous vous
êtes perdu aussi premier jeu de la
grosse boule on perd combien de points
ce premier jeu 20 20 combien de jeux à
l'émission 3 et il ya un total de
combien de boules à perdre ça
quelle belle classe sur moi qu'il sauve
comme ça c'est le règlement que le
paloma martinez d'être négatif au départ
d'encore 20 points verts voit si on
affiche la question pour tout le monde
à l'antenne au sujet des prix des
médicaments laquelle de ces informations
est la plus juste il peut y avoir une
qui est juste mais laquelle il a plus
juste est ce que ca
les entreprises fixent des prix de la
plupart des médicaments au canada
est ce que ces bébés les entreprises et
gouvernements décident en
en du prix des médicaments est ce que
c'est c'est les forces du marché dicte
les prix des médicaments au canada ou
encore est-ce que c'est dé l'état
canadien réglemente le prix des
médicaments
quelle est la formation qui est la plus
juste aujourd'hui la baie
soyez deal avait consensus entre les
deux ça ma mère est sa meilleure chose
de khurais beaucoup de bon sens oui
c'est intéressant mais le truc c'est que
dépendant si on est on a une assurance
médicaments
les prix peuvent différer parce que on
puisque les procurer auprès du
gouvernement on passe dans le pouvoir
d'achat de gouvernement pour des prix
moindres et je sais que c'est pas des
alors j'ai dit non
alors qu'est ce que vous êtes ap où je
le dirai je dirais à vous dire il ya
d'accord alors si vous avez répondu
b on va vous l'accordé je dis ça pour le
moment avant que notre invité s'exprime
sur la question officiellement ce serait
plus plus juste de dire des plus justes
mais pas dit que c'est tout à fait la
même chose c'est bon ça l'état canadien
réglemente le prix des médicaments c'est
à dire qu'il est là pour si un doute il
ya une vérification des prix et il a un
pouvoir de décider en au final quel
travail oit j'ai l'impression que c'est
ça ggd pression après avoir tout lu sur
la question 13h au moins 2,3 sur les
encyclopédies médicales moi je recule
devant rien alors on va aller traire
notre y a que vous qui a perdu ses
boules aujourd'hui
oui mais c'est bizarre parce que je suis
la seule qui prend des médicaments ouais
et je sais que si moi j'y vais avec ma
couverture d'assurance ouais le
pharmacien va me charger plus cher que
si je n'étais pas sous cette couverture
et puis j'avais plus que 65 alors on
fait à venir bertrand bolduc président
de l'ordre des pharmaciens du québec
vous aviez vu juste c'est bien
responsable des pharmaciens au québec
est avec nous bonjour monsieur bolduc
bonjour alors évidemment moi je me perds
et je me suis amusé à faire ce que mes
collègues s'ils perdent également et qui
réglemente le prix des médicaments au
canada commençons par ça avoir parlé du
prix des médicaments aux états unis
voyons comment ça se passe chez nous
alors la réponse de votre question
c'était des bébés alors alors des
pourquoi parce qu'évidemment sont
brevetées donc il n'ya qu'un fournisseur
seulement une souvent de compagnies
innovatrices le conseil d'examen des
prix des médicaments brevetés voir fixer
un maximum du berry et ça c'est en
comparaison à un groupe d'environ sept
pays actuellement
donc avec des pays européens les
etats-unis la suisse et ses rangs on va
en voir fixer un prix maximum que des
compagnies ne peuvent pas dépasser pour
les mecs profiter là évidemment il ya
beaucoup de débats au canada ça fait un
an que ça dure antilles on devra avoir
un mécanisme encore plus précis un peu
plus qu'un peu plus de fermeté pour
pouvoir faire fléchir les prix des fois
qui semble un petit peu artificiellement
gonflés par les entreprises
pharmaceutiques dont plusieurs sont
canadiennes où en est présentement la
discussion brièvement sur cette question
alors il ya aussi les gouvernements
provinciaux qui négocient les prix des
médicaments est breveté également les
médicaments généré donc au canada donc
deux paliers une négociation le fédéral
le provincial donc la ramq huissier au
québec mais les autres formules
apprenait sur le fond également négocié
librairie pour les avoir les plus
possible donc on peut on peut assurément
des au canada on paie beaucoup moins
champ de médicaments aux états unis en
général c'est pour ça que au dessus de
la frontière on est chez nous mais si on
se compare juste une dernière question
en ce concerne ouais bah je sais pas si
on se console j'ai vu j'ai vu quelque
part j'ai pas pu confirmer la ferme et
qu'on serait troisième au niveau des
duos prix des médicaments comparer un
certain groupe de nations je sais pas
vous avez les détails là dessus oui ben
effectivement le conseil d'examen les
prix des médicaments brevetés
quand je vous disais
regarde certes différents pays mais il
ya un projet de loi au niveau fédéral
pour revoir le pen ni deux pays auxquels
on voit se comparer et ça pourra faire
descendre la médiane des prix des
médicaments brevetés l'avenir alors on
va éliminer les etats-unis la suisse qui
sont plus chers
on va remplacer par d'autres pays où
c'est moins cher comme le sable
australie et on va avoir des prix pour
le moins cher dans quelques années pour
les médicaments brevetés
mais il faut faire attention évidemment
parce que si on décourage trop les
compagnies finir commercialisé chez nous
on aura peut-être pas accès à tous donc
il faut trouver un bon équilibre entre
les deux réduire les primes en même
temps maintenir l'innovation et l'accès
aux canadiens aux nouveaux produits
pharmaceutiques je pense qu'il convient
ici de faire intervenir la plus grande
consommatrice d'un médicament à
l'émission j'ai pas le choix je voulais
vous demander le modèle australien on
parle beaucoup du modèle australien je
crois qui est très intéressant ou est ce
que c'est le money le modèle néo
zélandais ou là les prix des médicaments
génériques ou les autres breveté sont
beaucoup moins cher qu'au canada
effectivement mais bel élan les
médicaments sont moins chers ça vient
avec sa un problème évidemment parce que
si vous êtes un producteur de
médicaments soient américains ou
asiatiques
vous allez vendre vos produits d'abord
vous en donne le plus beau et à des
problèmes de pénurie médicaments avant
les autres parce que il est libre et les
prix sont vraiment très bonne si au
canada quand même on se débrouille bien
pour les médicaments génériques que les
prix sont assez raisonnables dans
l'ensemble mais il faut toujours faire
attention parce que l'équilibré d'un
bris un art et un prix trop faible qui
causaient buneri un prix trop élevé qui
passe juste et c'est pas toujours facile
à trouver mais ces petites mains
expliqué me débrouiller mieux que la
nouvelle zélande au niveau des pénuries
est un peu plus cher que chez eux et en
général puisque on est un petit marché
ben il faut parfois et s'assurer d'un
approvisionnement stable aussi sur ses
pas facile non plus de sens mais cette
semaine on voyait qu'il y avait des
pénuries de tamoxifène
qui est un médicament très important
pour beaucoup de gens au canada
comment expliquer ça le tamoxifène c'est
un tel exemple dans le produit qui qui
est essentielle surtout pour les femmes
qui ont eu qui ont souffert d'un cancer
du sein pour éviter les récidives
alors vous pouvez imaginer comment c'est
essentiel et parce que c'est un
médicament dont le raid huile de curry
et qui passe est un pas faire ce
médicament n'est pas de la
chimiothérapie classique mais c'est un
médicament qui est quand même un peu
spéciale au niveau sécurité alors il ya
beaucoup moins 1 de producteurs et il
faut s'assurer de l'approvisionnement un
prix raisonnable et leur bain s'il ya un
problème de qualité à un endroit où
signant une des sociétés aux cesser la
commercialisation ça dérange l'equilibre
et l'on se retrouve en pénurie
heureusement pour ce produit là
présentement les pharmaciens peuvent
préparer eux mêmes des capsules pour les
patientes en attendant que le produit
commercial revient sur le marché dans
con on est en train d'éviter la
catastrophe mais il faut garder l'oeil
ouvert et très attentif aux stocks de ce
médicament qui très précieux pour ses
patients que justement en ce moment au
monde des images d'un reportage de
cilicie qui parlent de cette pénurie de
médicaments contre le cancer on n'y a
pas qu'un seul médicament il y en aurait
deux autres également sur la liste
en ce moment les médicaments en pénurie
on a alors constamment vous seriez
surpris je reçois des alertes
tous les jours une liste de médicaments
en pénurie à tous les jours bon parfois
c'est ça ma marque et on peut se
débrouiller avec les autres fabricants
on a eu récemment chimiothérapie com -
comme vous le dites sur caen pénurie est
ça la nécessité que nos pharmaciens
surtout en milieu hospitalier prioriser
patients s'échange du stock en creux on
s'assurer que les genres tant pour le
traitement c'est sur un très difficile
et ça nous occupe un peu trop on
aimerait passer plus de temps à soigner
les gens plutôt qu'à s'occuper du stock
qui manquent mais c'est un grand souci
et l'équilibré toujours très fragile
pour certains produits parce qu'on n'a
pas beaucoup de fabricants
donc il faut être extrêmement vigilant
et
les stocks sont précieux lorsqu'on les a
bon voilà on a mis en temps ensemble la
table pour ce qui est de la réalité
canadienne au niveau de la disponibilité
des médicaments et des prix c'était
essentiel au départ une conversation sur
l'injection de dollars américains dans
notre économie pourra lire nous soutirer
les médicaments et les apporter là bas
revenons-en à c'est à ces manoeuvres
je bois d'oeuvre sur un peu négatif
comme terme est assez à ces gestes que
pose présentement l'administration
américaine aux promesses faites par le
démocrate bernie sanders tout ça ça s'en
va dans une direction il ya nettement un
courant aux états unis pour dire on a
besoin de médicaments moins chers et une
piste c'est au canada qu'on va la
trouver
comment ça comment ça se passe
actuellement c'est sûr qu'au canada
parce qu'on a deux vies deux niveaux de
gouvernement qui négocie les prix pour
tout le monde on a des prix plus bas
pour tout le monde alors qu aux etats
unis si vous êtes assurés par une grande
compagnie d'assurance
vous avez quelqu'un qui négocient vauban
vous n'avez pas d'assurance
ça va pas très bien vous n'avez pas de
lévis négociation vous avez payé le gros
prix
et c'est ce qui cause ou si monsieur
center évidemment utilisent cette
situation pour démontrer que devrait
avoir une couverture sociale beaucoup
plus grand pour les médicaments aux
états unis comme nous on l'a au canada
alors les jeux c était assez éclatent à
remplir une autre puce me rechercher
d'insuline deux côtés de la frontière
évidemment les gens ont été frappés par
différence de prix c'est pas facile il
faut s'assurer que nous on garde les
stocks on a ici pour nos bastien d'ici
parce que souvent même banco de
l'insuline s'est fabriqué aux états unis
alors c'est un peu un pixar quand on
expose des idées ziva le canada y
compris importe aux états unis par la
suite parce que c'est moins cher
les américains doivent eux-mêmes mettre
en place les mesures pour négocier les
prix de leurs médicaments pour leurs
populations
c'est ce que monsieur senders a mis en
évidence lors de son de cette petite
visite en ontario à windsor récemment et
c'est ce que monsieur trampo dit par la
suite du ben voyons pour devrait faire
ça mais alors nous on est un peu utilisé
comme levier de négociation levier de 2
politique pour l'abattoir qui m'inquiète
encore présents aux états unis pour les
prochaines élections américaines
vous dites qu'on a dû on a des pénuries
au canada vous dites tous les jours on a
une pénurie de médicaments
est ce que si on commence à vendre nos
médicaments aux états unis on sera
toujours le même problème comment va
pouvoir pallier à ces pénuries s'il nous
en prennent encore plus vous avez par
exemple il ya même un chercheur
américain qui a publié là dessus qui a
démontré que si les américaines
d'assainir le médicament canada on
tiendrait pas deux trois mois alors je
suis évidemment on est beaucoup moins
les dix fois moins il faut il faut
éviter ça à tout prix alors comment on
fait ça va évidemment les sociétés
américaines qui commercialise au canada
vont s'assurer que leurs stocks reste au
canada parce qu'ils ont peur ils ont
pour avantage
1 les exporter leurs produits aux
états-unis - puisqu'ils vendent plus
cher là-bas c'est la première garantie
qu'on a il singly condé des contacts les
grossistes canadiens que ce 6 novembre
au canada
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que les pharmacies au canada
mais ils doivent servir les patients
canadiens ne sont pas des grossistes
mehdi fabrique 1 et informations au
québec ou en ontario ou ailleurs ne peut
servir que des patients canadiens avec
des prescriptions de médecins canadiens
lorsqu'une deuxième ligne de défense que
nous avons en place s'assurer que les
produits ne retourne positive
évidemment si un touriste américain qui
passage au canada et qui ont un problème
de médicaments on va le dépanner c'est
sûr mais on en fournira pas
nécessairement pour deux ans juste pour
lui faire économiser des sous à ce que
des formations ont une responsabilité
sur le suivi des mises 15 c'est pas
juste servir le mm s'assurer de bien
utiliser et de façon sécuritaire
s'il paraît un don de chez lui aux
étudiants de contrôle et c'est pas notre
métier notre métier c'est de servir la
population d'ici et s'assurer que nos
stocks
thomas ici à travers les fabricants des
grossistes les pharmaciens
mais voilà évidemment il faut moniteurs
et surtout s'assurer que la personne qui
joue avec
est-ce que vous avez les moyens
un de monitorer ça est-ce que vous avez
moins de savoir cette personne est déjà
venu il ya deux mois et elle reviendra
dans deux mois est-ce que vous avez les
moyens techniques de le faire bien sûr
comme vous savez les toutes les
pharmacies sont informatisées et suivre
leurs patients souvent ils vont même pré
programmés les nouvelles même si on a
quelqu'un qui vient avec une adresse
américaine déjà nous fait sourciller on
veut s'assurer bon vous êtes pas le
visiteur un problème vous avez oublié
quelque chose posé beaucoup de questions
évidemment
hélas si nous demande des gens
n'arrêtent besoin pour six mois un
instant breton et quand chez vous et on
va exercer sa d'autre part des
grossistes sont en mesure de jeter un
coup d'oeil sur les commandes des voix
les variations dans le temps de ces
commandes là pour s'assurer que obs
si un pharmacien tout à coup se met à
commander dix fois plus de shillings
habituellement maloya un souci on va les
voir chez eux ils vont empêcher nous
avons envoyé un inspecteur et on va
s'assurer que les personnes qui
s'entretuent si bien les patients
canadiens mais c'est possible
comment expliquer que une personne qui
va dans une bannière particulière une
pharmacie particulière va payer plus
cher moins cher un générique ou un
médicament d'origine parce que ça arrive
ben pour le prix des médicaments pour
les gens qui sont assurées au québec on
a un système libre et de privés publiés
que c'est la même chose dans les autres
provinces au canada des pharmaciens
négocié des honoraires avec le
gouvernement donc le système public qui
sont fixes par médicaments alors que
pour des honoraires pour les personnes
qui sont couverts par les assurances
privées
les honoraires sont variables alors on
c'est vrai que pour plusieurs produits
de prix est un peu plus cher pour les
assurer du privé mais pour certains
autres sont moins chers alors un produit
très peu coûteux par exemple soient
moins chers pour le privé qu'au public
mais pour les produits plus dispendieux
ou être un peu plus cher donc les
horaires sont pas fixés de la même façon
et n'inclut pas nécessairement non plus
les mêmes services
à voir au public les oeuvres être
facturé séparément alors qu'au privé
je vous dirais que présentement le
modèle est est un peu plus
mutualiser ce qui n'est pas idéal et
c'est pas l'homme qui négocie des les
honoraires évidemment avec les payeurs
mais l'association des pharmaciens
propriétaires ici au québec et dans le
reste du canada c'est la même chose
comptant près de revoir ce mode de
rémunération qui soit beaucoup mieux
moduler temps au public qu'au privé non
seulement en fonction du prix du
médicament ce qu'ils peuvent pas
vraiment de sens mais plutôt au niveau
de service qui est nécessaire au niveau
de suivi alors je vous donne un exemple
c'est sûr que ma fille de 22 ans qui
peint anovulants nécessite beaucoup
moins de suivi que ma mère de 76 ans qui
prend à huit ou dix médicaments alors
les pharmaciens devraient recevoir plus
pour une patients qui demandent plus de
soin est moins bonne personne qui aime
qui demandent moins de suivi ces
versions qu'on se dirige pour justement
arriver à des à des honoraires qui font
beaucoup plus de sens quand vous allez
chez le dentiste vous payez plus cher et
plus de caries et vous payez moins cher
dans l'avant port c'est bien évident
alors ça devrait être comme sur les
médicaments éventuellement mais pourquoi
une différence de prix pour le même
médicament dans différentes bannières
c'est le prix du médicament en lui même
est le même pour tout le monde
les honoraires des pharmaciens qui
varient nécessairement mais les produits
eux mêmes ils sont ils ont ils sont tous
au même prix puisqu'ils sont négociés
par le gouvernement et le gouvernement
s'assure qu'ils paient tout le monde
cherche donc on a daily même prix pour
tout le monde c'est quoi un horaire de
pharmaciens pas normal mais moyens vous
allez beaucoup le nageur ou publiques au
québec est d'environ 9 10 dollars alors
que vous privez peut varier de 3 à 52
pas demander ce qui est nécessaire de
faire si je vous sers un produit qui
nécessitent réfrigération qui nécessite
beaucoup plus de conseils de
démonstration fausse passe du temps avec
vous pour vous l'expliquer pour le
suivre où je vous assure que dans
quelques jours toutes et bienvenue vous
aviez pas d'effets secondaires
alors évidemment ce soit sans dieu qu'un
body pour lesquelles je vous donne un
exemple de la vitamine d par exemple
j'ai à peu près rien vous y apprend que
tout va bien se passer si vous prenez
tous les jours est serein
alors c'est sûr que
ça varie grandement selon les conditions
restent entre eux est un peu normal
parce que le risque de perte est plus
grand pour les produits réfrigérés d'une
pompe pour l'asthme a demandé plus
d'explications et cetera donc c'est un
peu variable en fonction de ça mathieu
vous avez une dernière question pour
juste à revenir sur les états unis
si jamais il décide de prendre des
médicaments gagner à ce qu'ils peuvent
comment ça va se passer si jamais il
décide de vraiment aller de l'avant et à
négocier que le canada présentement on
les laisserait pas faire c'est à dire
que témiscamingue heures pour pourrait
pas provenir d'une pharmacie et pourrait
pas provenir des grossistes alors
faudrait que eux ils demandent à leurs
propres filiales sur des filières les
compagnies américaines ou internationale
devant nous étonner je vois pas je pense
plutôt qu'on est en jeu c'est être
d'autres journalistes on est dans une
pièce de théâtre il nous on est un peu
entre les deux parties ont un ancêtre de
faire valoir d'un côté ou de l'autre
selon dans les positions ce qu'on peut
imaginer d'ailleurs madame pelosi
démocrate et président de la chambre des
représentants a déjà proposé un projet
de loi pour réduire le prix des
médicaments d'abord avec ce que vous
allez probablement voir si la campagne
électorale américaine plus officiel dans
les prochains mois
c'est des projets des promesses de
réduire le prix des médicaments pour les
américains je pense avoir un des thèmes
de la campagne peut-être pas un thème
majeur des vais je n'en croyais pas dire
pas de souci pour le moment on n'est pas
dans une pièce de molière le malade
imaginaire ça va merci beaucoup d'être
venu à l'émission aujourd'hui très moi
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses sur ce
qui se passe ici chez nous au niveau des
prix essentiel de le savoir maintenant
merci beaucoup merci bout de mes grands
plaisirs
avant c'était bertrand bonneau du
président de l'ordre des pharmaciens du
québec qui démarre c'est quelqu'un qui
sait s'exprimer
ouais on n'est pas payé pour rien mais
ce que j'aime beaucoup chez lui c'est
qu'il s'est un peu cliché mais il
correspond exactement à l'image
rassurante qu'on se fait du pharmacien
parce que les temps est long way et puis
on sait qu'ils vérifient et
c'est se poser c'est systématique
c'était il ya douceur dans le jet ski
font également d'accord parce qu on
pourrait en avoir fait l'expérience je
dirais magazines et des fois vos
bannières oui parce que vous par univers
mais il ya aussi le service qu'on reçoit
qui est important moi je veux pas nommer
de compagnie mais je le ferai pas non
plus je suis aussi il faut faire
attention on parlait du code de
déontologie à l'émission un peu plus tôt
n'est ce pas alors voilà on l'appelait
qu'aujourd'hui à l'émission foot est
très sérieusement on va jouer ensemble
maintenant au deuxième jour de la grosse
boule combien de boules à perdre entre 1
8 et puis la question n'est pas facile
je vous préviens que son affiche à la à
l'écran attendons voir
voici une fiole d'insuline de 30 $ au
canada se vend aux états unis à quel
prix selon vous est ce que ca à plus de
400 dollars
j'aimerais avoir qui casse un peu là
comme matthew à 400 da est-ce que c'est
b à plus de 350 dollars est ce que c'est
c'est à plus de 200 dollars
ou est ce que c'est des com de vitamine
d à plus de 100 dollars
je tiens à dire que je fait rajeunir
tout le monde regarde sa voix lors des
sauts avec les voix sont affectés alors
la bonne réponse
moi j'aurais dit à plus de 200 à plus de
ça c'est donc c'est pour matthew
d'accord parce que quand même 300 cc
énorme crise en cinq ans oui c'est
énorme je vais rester raisonnable tant
que 200 ok moi je vais aller avec 18 la
première réponse je n'avais pas choisi d
d'accord alors vous avez tous les peurs
du boys band à plus de 410 et 450
dollars des amis alors on se demande
pourquoi ils traversent la frontière qui
veulent acheter les médicaments ils
sentent pas de l'eau est souvent celle
de l'insuline qui est fabriqué ici alors
essaie de comprendre ce qui se passe
élisons un sérieux problème de contrôle
des prix moi je voudrais mais le plus
ironique c'était quand même quand ils
nous expliquaient les entreprises
américaines ventes de médicaments au
canada et ils vendent plus cher chez eux
qu' au canada
mais d'ailleurs trois ans avait fait une
remarque là dessus nous avait dit qu'en
haut les américaines n'ont qu'à aller au
canada
mais ce qu'il ne comprenait pas c'est
qu'il mettait dans trop gondi ici les
entreprises américaines
oui parce qu'il ferait moins d'argent
parce qu'elle a marché petit hic la mode
donc tous les américains
fini au canada pour acheter les
médicaments at il été question qui est
un prix nobel de la paix a offert à troy
mais je pense qu'on va lui offrir le
prix nobel de l'économie
ce que je veux faire une recommandation
à ce sujet étaient eux parce que c'est
un sujet sérieux et parce qu à plusieurs
facettes à ça évidemment on a les
reportages des entrevues et il est tout
ce qu'on a fait récemment sur la
question des médicaments au canada
seulement c'est très détaillé on va
afficher notre vidéo qui s'appelle pour
en savoir plus
alors pour en savoir plus vous allez
retrouver plusieurs de vos reportages
maryse vous entrevue de vos articles
on va commencer à regarder vous allez
vous reconnaître tout de suite
l'importation par les américains le
médicament canadien causera des pénuries
je pense que c'est de vous ça où le prix
des médicaments canada s'unissent dans
la course à la présidence des états unis
c'est de vous ça alors ça c'est pô dans
l'immédiat on parle de la crise on va
descendre un petit peu le long de cette
page qui accompagne démission
aujourd'hui pénurie de médicaments
contre le cancer au canada ottawa suit
le dossier on a parlé au début de
l'entrevue avec notre invité
toujours aucune solution permanente à la
pénurie nationale de médicament pour le
cancer troisième section en médicaments
un bon système de base passe par un
système un régime universel justement
clic et on va aller vers l'antarctique
près comme ça qui est derrière donc il a
rassemblé des gens à l'autre
c'est ça d'autres professeurs avec lui
pour justement demande au gouvernement
de mettre sur pied un système national
vous reconnaissez cet homme tout à fait
qui est il mais je gagne en liberté à
tahoua il est intervenu à plusieurs
antennes c'est un spécialiste de la
gestion des médicaments
il regarde ça d'un point de vue
économique c'est la première fois qu'il
avait interviewé c'était pour les people
qui coûte vraiment cher et qui a
augmenté et a mené au canada on a
commencé à faire entrer des marques
génériques plutôt que la marque
et puis qu'est ce que j'aime beaucoup
dans vos artistes que vous affichez
d'autres articles à la fin notre article
sur le même thème ce qui permet à
l'internaute
de voyager à travers le site web de
radio-canada international je le
recommande
[Rires]
on est prêt pour le troisième tour de la
grosse boule allons-y kong où la perdre
oui vous en avez perdu pour moi j'ai 30
55 cents alors que à 70 75 bon ça y est
on se tutoie tout le monde à condition
[Rires]
ok voici la question la fiche on l'a
fait chaud voilà troisième tour quel est
le prix moyen au canada
marie vous en parlait beaucoup la wii
mais un médicament générique ça dépend
de quel médicament 8 mais là on parle du
prix moyen
alors on veut pas de bétail on veut le
prix moyen de tous ces médicaments
génériques
il ya une enquête à ce sujet récemment
est-ce que c'est à 19h45 ça c'est ça la
folle l'honoraire du fer nationale
je précise et un astérisque de l'acfo
ajouté est ce que c b 26 dollars 13
je suis très près six mois la wii est ce
que c'est c'est 72 $ 0 200 canadiens ou
est ce que c'est des 105 dollars et 18
sous le prime moyenne au canada de
médicaments génériques
moi je dirais 26 13 réponse b 26-13 donc
bingo pour non c'est pas à moi je perds
tous mes points depuis le début alors
est-ce que tu devrais me rallier à
matthew où est ce que je devrais aller
avec
je sais pas avoir d'éléments inédits ce
doublé est nécessaire encore de la
réponse non je vais aller avec nature
mais prend le maxxi n'est pas dernier
alors j'ai fini je vais vous êtes une
explication on va regarder l'écran des
données des machines et choix mais j'ai
voulu mais j'ai voulu faire ça bien
c'est que les prix canadiens restent
beaucoup plus bas que les prix
américains c'est encourageant je vous
donne l'explication ici sur
l'association canadienne du médicament
générique regarder ni les gifles le prix
moyen d'une ordonnance produits
médicaments génériques est passé de 26
dollars 13 en 2009 à 19h45 en 2018
en comparaison le prix moyen pour des
médicaments de marque comme je sais pas
où
fighter et compagnie était de 72 dollars
2 en 2009 et 105 dollars 18 sous leur
dernier en soit s'il y en avait joué il
ya dix ans j'aurais gagné
[Rires]
alors là vous êtes à 20 points et où
l'on vous gagnez moi je suis à 0 le
dernier jet à 77 50 ans survit de survie
je quitte le seuil et 28 hockey regarde
au sort vous allez dire qu'elle est vous
allez dire vous avez regardé la mater
sujet de la semaine je réponds pas ou
par non vous devez de me dire qu'il
était l'image de la semaine qu'elle
était l'image la semaine mais là ça nous
prend des indices non société trans part
sociale est mise aussi économie société
économie où est-ce qu'on est au canada
prenez tout cas notre société économie
est ce que ça traite de l'immigration
n'ont pas peur de se voir
non est-ce que c'est au québec que
partout au canada
c'est partout qu'elle est là est-ce que
ça traite de résultats des élections non
sur ledit waxeet message ou c'est un
facteur qui joue dur à la soirée des
élections
landi pontife un facteur qui jouait
encore à peine neuf minutes avant de
perdre de sa télé est ce que vraiment
l'un à 10 ans je ne sais pas il est
14h45 le changement d'avis il a fait du
troc là tu cette semaine
alors il des ventes et c'est cet article
on va les voir sur le site sera basé sa
bulle mille paires clic
mais c'est un débat qui y mettiez
partout en moi qui suis originaire
d'europe on en parle beaucoup l'union
européenne est en train de réfléchir à
arrêter le changement d'heure
complètement
j'ai lu qu'au canada le villes le font
aussi c'est vraiment un sujet qui fait
tout ça a commencé par la coloscopie
tanner café du retail denis parise
aritz abandonné oui mes gars la
saskatchewan qui ne changent jamais
d'heure bouchard n'a jamais choqué
exactement depuis 1918
il ya une heure de différence avec le
manitoba selon que c'est l'hiver ou
l'été
l'alberta et la main ya des gens qui
disaient problème si on ne change pas
d'heure en colombie-britannique et qu'on
présente les matchs de hockey on les
regarde là quelle heure et est ce que ça
va commencer trop tôt koné volcanique
que ce soit à la bonne heure même les
plus grands marchés clés évidemment il
ya plusieurs on a montré les images de
l'image la semaine oui d'accord je fais
juste vérifié le jeu des patins parce
que je mange conduit sans regarder
alors est ce que vous savez si on va
garder leur avance et d'été c'est comme
ça qu'ils appellent au canada
ça n'est pas d endroit je pense
britannique voulait garder leur avance
est ok mais peut-être qu'ailleurs au
canada pourrait garder leur normale ou
leur recul et je crois que leurs
diverses l'heure normale face et gmt gmt
plus que jean clet parce qu'on va garder
ces gmt pour green est bénigne chez st
mais par exemple toronto étant tout de
cleveland voix haute qui nous donne
pourquoi que moi je vous la finesse pas
mon fort alors toronto est en haut de la
ville de cleveland est ce que les deux
super vu leur elle même la rumeur oui
c'est intéressant mais c'est comme en
espagne le portugal à l'heure anglaise
alors que l'espagne alors françaises
espagnoles européennes et se construit
les trains passer la frontière ou
changer d'heure mais est-ce qu'on suit
les fuseaux horaires c'est à peu près
oui mais bon ça va quand même qu'ils
sont très proches et on change quand
même d'heure du coup de préparer je
pense si le canada décide de rester le
plus changé de là que les états unis
continuent à le faire
à peine ont traversé la frontière on
changerait d'heure et ben moi je ne sais
pas comment on pourrait gérer ça je
pense qu'il faudrait que les pays
s'accordent pour le faire il ya
évidemment le pire problème c'est les
gens à la nasa qui suivent des
opérations de leurs des robots sur mars
parce qu'il ya ces 23 heures sur mars
une journée alors à chaque jour de
travail ils doivent venir une journée
une heure plus tard travailler une heure
plus tard à travailler une heure plus
tard travailler au bout d'eux mêmes du
de 23 jours ils sont rendus à la 24
heures de différence
c'était moi pas là les chiffres sont
approximatifs et peut-être vingt trois
histoires de l'année bissextile ou là on
a une journée de moins oui
ah oui ils veulent charger ça aussi ben
non mais il faudrait changer la donne
alors ça pourrait qu'on dit sur le
problème du voile un débat mais il n'y a
personne qui est ce qu'ils aient eu des
propositions concrètes qui
fonctionnerait je ne crois pas encore
c'est parce qu'il va y avoir une
conversation entre les premiers
ministres des provinces est ce que le
nombre de bits britannique veut faire si
requis la plus avancée la faim sont là
je veux un référendum auprès des
citoyens puis les gens c'est fini on
veut arrêter de changer d'air parce que
il n'y a pas de raisons économiques
maintenant mais le problème encore de
vitalic avec leur avancée c'est que le
soleil se lèverait beaucoup plus tard le
matin ce qui veut dire que les gens
seraient pas encore tout à fait réveillé
peut-être parce qu'ils arrivent au
travail parce qu'ils seraient souvent en
situation de noirceur
alors ça passe et seagate répond je
pense si on est matinal ou abaissé jeudi
soir
retravailler cette véritable noirceur
c'est bien connu on va écouter
blague à part il est qu à l'heure - 10
mai exactement - triskell 2 - 11h50 en
oeuvre sa mini one is l'heure de l'est à
parfait alors 11h50 presque ok alors une
chose qu'on n'a pas les seconds parce
que je vous dis merci beaucoup merci et
matthew leisel d'être venu cette semaine
merci stéphane marie jobin également
merci beaucoup et on avait un quatrième
micro micro mais c'était pour vous faire
languir on l'a pas montré beaucoup à
l'antenne c'est l'invité mystère ouest
et mister à la semaine prochaine bah
[Musique]